this question comes from key concrete007
at 55 i've become reflective and decided
to take dmt
not for recreational purposes but to
open my mind to fear and amazement
i've been an atheist all my life at one
point during my ayahuasca experience i
raised my hand skyward and said god
forgive me i'm no longer an atheist my
question what are your thoughts on the
controlled use of dmt or psychedelics in
general
good question
i know these days many people are
involved in
using
you know some of the substances
to access virtual realities and in fact
there are you know some native
um
teaching in different
places where they use that
and um
i tried those
when i was in college lsb and things
like that and i had spiritual
experiences and openings and
what i remember from my experience i did
it several times you know in
the 60s and
early 70s
but then after
when i started having spiritual
experiences
on my own without them
i did not go back
to the using those substances and and i
was wondering about the other day why
didn't i
it's not like somebody told me
don't do it or it just dropped out of my
mind and and now
i'm not that interested but i do
hear about it from students from other
people that they experiment with these
and
some of them have good experience
and especially
for somebody who is
find it difficult to access a spiritual
dimension
it can can be i see it
helping them
do it once or twice it opened them up in
a way that they weren't being able to be
open and that way they
saw something about themselves in
reality they couldn't see before and
that is really helpful for their
development
and evolution
so i think that way i've seen it being
useful that way
i wouldn't recommend that somebody use
it as their way of spiritual practice
unless they are part of some indigenous
tribe and they have their own
you know way of dealing with it
i find many of the people who we were
talking about earlier who with a
megaphone shout their toe out to other
people in such a manner that doesn't
have people welcoming their toe they
tend to have in common that their
insights were precipitated by their
private use of psychedelics so do you
see that psychedelics to inform one's
philosophy or ontology etc as removed
from a community is somehow
net negative in some manner or not as
pure
well it's not that you know it's more
like
comparing my experiences from the 60s
and 70s on psychedelics
from my later experiences which happens
more spontaneously
there is a difference in quality it's
not the same
the psychedelic gives it the changes
thing some way
that is
not how reality is exactly
when you experience
you know
one's raw consciousness
and and
it it has the possibility of opening up
but it also opens up to other things
that are not true you know it because
also can magnify our imagination
and that's why people have bad trips you
know
because it could magnify anything
so um
i why i think about it is that
some traditions
like the ayahuasca tradition in south
america for instance
they have developed a way of working
with it
that they use it for you know
as part of their
spiritual practice
but i also seen some
americans who went there and
did that and they came back and their
spiritual access naturally was
got more narrow
hmm interesting see that goes back to
what i was referring to earlier about
path dependence so some people would say
no this lesson works and it works
ubiquitously but it also depends on
where you are one of the ways that i
like to conceptualize this i'm curious
if you i'm curious what your thoughts
are is that i see some westerners taking
on eastern approaches and vice versa
somewhat uncritically and i wonder if
that's always a net benefit because to
me it's akin to installing maxop force
installing mac software on your pc
you're going to get errors if it's not
compatible with how you grew up with
what your view is right now do you think
so i think there is there is a point
there occurred
in the sense that the
uh the eastern approach they have their
own world view
which is different from a western world
world view
for instance
um
both the indian spirituality and
buddhist spirituality
developed on being
free from samsara
right by the kosamsara which is the
ordinary world
and basically
because they believe in reincarnation
is that the idea is to not reincarnate
again
you want to be enlightened so they'll be
free from this world and not come back
again
and and the west we don't subscribe to
that kind of thing you know
incarnation coming back or whatever you
know for me
i don't know if that's true or not
see so i don't look at spirituality that
way
i i look at spirituality that is to
make life as complete as deep as
possible
and that means something else for later
right
see and so
so yeah so some people
adopt the eastern view of with all the
their philosophical or
metaphysical perspective of
reincarnation and um
and
you know and
leaving the world and
which which has in it a way of saying
that this world is
is no good that's you're here
you see
i
myself
i don't know i mean i'm i don't know i
mean i i have some experiences if i
incarnate whatever i don't know if
they're true or not
if they're real or not
and so i don't subscribe to that
so it's true if somebody who's watching
who takes on that like they're putting a
hat on
their brain
that
is just a hat on them it's not really uh
naturally
arisen inside within them
but the spiritual but however if
somebody takes the spiritual tradition
and take the practices and learn to
connect to the truth of who they are and
then that is independent of the
worldview
because you just what you are at this
moment
what you are at this moment has nothing
to do with the past or the future so
you're not thinking of
all the
you're free of the world of you
basically any world of view
in that way it could be useful yes and
many i think have found it useful that
way